cosmic wonder hitting us with
information about we Harrelson hid the
carnage new haircut leaks carnage first
look venom two trailer update finally
get a chance to wear this venom shirt
yep could never wear it before until
today maybe you have heard maybe you
haven't we did a video with the cosmic
Wonder finally video up on his channel
we talked about Wolverine fan casting a
lot of the pics were voted by you guys
and his subs as well and then we threw a
couple of our own in there it was a
really really fun video and I really
hope you guys go check it out link in
the description box and in the pin
comment or planning on shooting another
video to put up on this channel talking
about our fantastic four castings keep a
look at our our community page cuz we're
gonna have a pull up there as well if
I'm a bid on a spider-man hi right now
because I finally beat the spider-man
ps4 game and I'm a spider-man fan cosmic
Wonder provides the info we provide the
opinions let's do it
how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel where we talk
about Marvel and all things relating to
the MCU how are we got some of them our
aren't to news including a leaked first
look at the carnage symbiote the actual
carnage symbiote and not just Cletus
Kasady also severally kotas for so far
and based off of these leaked photos
that we've gotten for carnage it looks
like fans are not going to be
disappointed with how he's going to look
in the film we also have some venom two
trailer updates today that we'll talk
about in this video we expect it even
with the pandemic going on right now so
I hope everyone is staying safe while
I'd be sure to subscribe with
notifications turned on so you don't
miss any of the more videos while you're
in quarantine past the last time we left
Eddie Brock and the Venom symbiote they
were talking to Cletus Kasady Marik's
and in the movie will go on to inherit
the carnage symbiote there was a nice
little teaser for carnage in that scene
where Woody Harrelson's character Cletus
says when I get out there will be
carnage but let's talk about where
exactly he's located in this scene
because it's very important to the film
he is in the Ravencroft Institute in the
comics Cletus is being held in the
Ravencroft Institute he inherits the
carnage symbiote and carnage helps him
escape he escapes with Francis Louise
Barisan who is shriek and shriek has
already been confirmed to be in venom 2
and it's looking like we're going to
have a very similar story happen in the
movie if we take a look at this very
first leaked carnage symbiote photo we
can tell that it's behind a cage it
could be just like maximum carnage where
the carnage symbiote helps Cletus Kasady
break out of the rain room this is the
first seemingly real one that we've
gotten and it looks like it answers the
question that we've had for a pretty
long time of whether or not carnage is
actually going to bond with Cletus
Kasady while he's in the asylum and help
him break out in the movie but if we
take a look at this photo it does look
like the symbiote has already bonded
with Cletus Kasady if you noticed in the
first a venom film when the symbiotes
were on their own and not attached to a
human host they are kind of just a blob
they don't really have much shape or
form until
bond to a host once they bond to the
host they get their classic symbiote
form as we can see in this photo it
definitely looks like it's already
bonded to Cletus and it looks like this
is its hand and luckily it's sticking
true to the comic accurate version of
carnage we can see the razor-sharp claws
that it has and of course the symbiote
can morph into whatever it really wants
to take the formula but does have this
razor-sharp claws so it's nice to see
that we are going to get a somewhat
comic accurate version of carnage now
you may have seen another leaked photo
of the carnage symbiote and
unfortunately a lot of people do believe
that this is fake there is always the
possibility that it could be real but
the general consensus is that it's fake
now Sony seems to have a very similar
marketing plan for the trailers looks
like their films this was definitely
something done intentionally by Sony to
get the hype up for the trailer because
it was coming out in just a few days and
the fact that we are getting this leaked
photo of carnage means that the venom 2
trailer isn't that far away
the first venom had an October 1st
release date and venom 2 has an October
2nd release date the first teaser
trailers have got more venom was
February 8th and then the first official
trailer for the movie was April 23rd so
we're well past the point of where we
should have already received a teaser
trailer for venom 2 now of course the
affected but again the fact that we've
received this photo hubs carnage means
that the trailer is most likely going to
be happening very soon but let me know
what you think about this first
real leaked photo of the carnage
symbiote even though it's just an arm
and a hand do you like how it looks
let me know what you think in the
comments down below don't forget to give
the video a like and subscribe and
notifications turned on so you can enter
my giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
one or a ps4 I'm picking a winner at
five hundred and fifty thousand
subscribers as always thank you all so
much for watching well for guys we need
to get cosmic Wonder - 550 K as soon as
possible so please subscribe to his
channel guys great on getting the
information yeah I think I mean to
answer the first question up front I
think it looks friggin awesome
just that hand it might not seem like a
lot just because it is a hand but it's
easy to make something that that look
really bad and that looked very real it
was really unsettling it's a little bit
of a hand is actually quite eerie it
does look comics accurate I don't know
about that other photo that they don't
know for sure if it's real or not it
doesn't look like you would mesh well
with the hand as it just looks red and
gooey yeah doesn't look like it has that
intermingling red black kind of textural
sheen whatever you use to describe what
that visual drawing of carnage looks
like you know he looks like he's black
but almost shines red or something like
that well yeah I mean he's more than
just red doesn't look like there's no Al
of Reds yeah size outlines actually to
the design I love the look of the hand
it looks like a really great photo
realistic visualization of what that art
looks like because you know not so much
the questionable image but yeah just
that hand looks like these 'key
undefinable rope-like biological you
know flesh that yeah just looks really
jarring and looks really menacing the
idea of casting Woody Harrelson for it I
don't think it's a bad pic and it did to
have other photos of him on set where he
does have a different hairdo and he's
clearly not in the prison anymore maybe
he got a haircut too because you know
that's what happens when you're a
fugitive you usually change the hair
clean up the facial hair and I think too
with the fact that you got Andy Serkis
working on this I don't know how the
movie overall will be I'm also thinking
the visual effects will probably look
better like I thought venom look pretty
damn good in the first movie but I
imagine that he would want to make sure
a carnage looks great on screen he would
know how to work with a cinematographer
especially on how to really make that
shine I'm kind of curious what the first
teaser trailer will actually be like cuz
I remember the venom teaser trailer
didn't even have venom in it and it was
a letdown for a lot of people you do see
Eddie Brock freaking out the MRI machine
look like a horror movie but with no
venom here maybe this first image is all
you'll really see it's just a hand
you'll probably see some Woody
Harrelson's cletus but you maybe you'll
just see a hand popping out there as a
little tease at the end kind of like a
bit different Morbius where he turns at
the camera and is
real close-up on his face but you don't
get a lot of clear imagery of him I
think that'd be a great way to go about
it like you'll see venom in the trailer
you'll see any Brock and then just a
hand of carnage I feel like would be
really menacing how many we got at a
teaser trailer yet but at the same time
it was their first time doing the outing
for spin-off antihero character and I
don't think they need to be as heavily
reliant on early marketing for it and
maybe they're in the middle ground
because of the pandemic should we put
out a trailer now we might have to push
this movie so it's probably another
reason why we haven't gotten a trailer
yet as it stands there what we're
getting so far I think it looks pretty
freakin awesome yeah it got me really
excited to see partly because some of
the characters I associated with the
most because of you know spider-man was
those symbiote characters I remember
going to the comic book shop on you know
Ventura but just by me and seeing those
big cutouts and stuff so this is really
exciting and I do hope that in this new
movie they do pay more attention to
really making the the nitty gritty of
the physical forms of them the focus
because I thought the first venom did a
little too much with the whole the
symbiotes are gonna expand and crash
into each other and fight outside of
their host form and so now that you've
got two of the most iconic plus you know
more of the seven coming in I do hope
that they kind of square it between
carnage and venom in a more meaningful
way than in the first one and I like
Woody Harrelson a lot I know his general
demeanor is a bit calm for what Cletus
Kasady is as a character so I think this
would be a nice opportunity I hope that
he kind of goes a little crazy in this
role he's played Psychopaths before and
I think he can pull this off I don't
know what the script is at all or what
the full on plot is for the movie but I
think taking it off where it's already
bonded with him like let's say that
post-credit scene or remember if it was
post credit or mid credit let's say that
scene where Eddie Brock does go to visit
him in the first venom it's already been
bonded to him I think would be a better
jumping-off point that's my personal
taste for a personal flavor I think it
would actually blend more impact and
weight to why he goes to visit him - for
whatever reason I guess I expect just at
the moment through speculation that like
the prologue of the movie might be
Cletus being infected and then will life
cut yeah Tom Hardy later and for some
reason I just feel like this trailer
whenever we get it is going to start in
some kind of like buddy-buddy kind of
way
with Eddie Brock and Venom before you
know the [ __ ] drops I feel like I'm just
expecting some kind of light-hearted at
the start trailer that follows with
chaos and terror alright guys what do
you think of this carnage first look do
you trust and the woody of the
Harrelson's do you want Eminem to return
to do a theme song for venom - do you
think he should do the same exact song
but just add - at the end of the whole
subscribe to the real rejects subscribe
to cosmic wonder click on notification
bill can't you guys see